[Music]
my name is vellum I am the data science
platform lead for Gajic today we're
gonna be talking about some of the
lessons we learned scaling machine
learning at kojic on google cloud so if
we're already I'm gonna just dive in so
who or what is go Jake so go Jake is an
Indonesian technology startup so we have
a wide variety of products and services
and some of them are on the screen right
now the one that we're most famous for
is our ride hailing a service go ride
and the image the photo actually shows
you what the service does it's a woman
being taken on one of these motorcycles
to a destination the reason why it's not
a car and it's a motorcycle is because
of the unique challenges in Indonesia so
a lot of people don't know this but in
Indonesia or Indonesia is one of the
largest countries in the world by
population I have over 260 million
people so it's the fourth largest
country in the world by population and
they have a lot of unique challenges
with public infrastructure and traffic
congestion and the way that Indonesians
have solved this problem is by using
motorcycles to get around and they also
have their own motorcycle taxis called
objects and when we originally started
we started as a call center for objects
so it is offline there's no application
it's completely disconnected you just
call in and we send energy and to take
to take you to your destination so
originally our founders launched the
service and there was a great growth and
demand for it because the traffic is so
bad an engine Indonesia that the service
really solved workday problems for
Indonesians and they continued to
collect information about what products
our customers wanted in Indonesia and in
2015 we launched our first mobile
application was just the modest bundle
of products so the key products there
are go ride the ride hailing on
motorcycles go food so that's food
delivery also on motorcycles and then
things like go Mart's grocery shopping
and other logistic services
and when we launched this initial
application the the uptake was
incredible so we hit hyper growth very
quickly and the mount in Indonesia was
insatiable because it solved so many of
the daily problems that Indonesians had
getting around the city and so over the
next couple of years we launched a bunch
of products not just that random we've
always been a very data-driven company
we've always looked at what the
customers wanted and launched very
targeted products to them so currently
we are a unicorn one of the few unicorns
in Asia or in Southeast Asia and we've
got eighteen products that we've
launched in the application and many
more that are not in the application in
2018 we are focusing on international
expansion but let's talk a bit about our
home indonesia so our app has been
downloaded almost 80 million times we
operate in 60 cities throughout
indonesia and in many of our product
verticals we're actually the largest
player so if i can just talk to two or
three of those for ride-hailing we have
more than a million drivers on our
platform on a typical day you'll have
hundreds of thousands of drivers online
at the same time servicing our customers
for go food our food delivery service we
have more than 200,000 merchants on our
platform and we call them merchants
because it's not just restaurants it's
also moms and pops that have that are
selling food from their garages so this
platform that we've built really allows
for a kind of socio-economic mobility
enables people to rise up from from
poverty
so the third product that I wanted to
highlight is go pay is one of the
leading Emani platforms that we've
launched in Southeast Asia so we have
many different products and I just
wanted to kind of highlight the scale at
which we're operating so along with that
is its data so this visualization
represents with some of the data points
that we're dealing with its
visualization of Jakarta the capital
city of Indonesia where each pixel
represents a person being dropped
or picked up on a annoyed girl right
private platform so this is just one
time of data point that we have on a
single product but we have many types of
products and data points and data
science plays a key role in our
organization and machine learning as
well when you have all these decisions
being made in real time machine learning
is critical to making those decisions
but the business no organization look to
data science also to understand our
customers and especially with
international expansion looming we
wanted to understand what the unique
demands of our customers were in
different markets so as a data science
platform lead it's my responsibility to
make sure our data scientists or as
efficient as possible right so that
their that their time is being used
correctly and that they have the right
tools available to them especially with
international expansion you don't want
to just add more data scientists you
want to really add leverage to the
existing ones that you have so I
launched an investigation into our data
scientists we're spending their time to
see if we can't improve their efficiency
and when we launched this investigation
one of the data scientists on screen
Darius came to us and said hey I've got
a lot of projects that I'm working on
right now I'm actually getting a bit
swamped and maybe you can focus your
investigation on me and see if you can't
optimize the way I'm doing things there
is very representative of a typical data
scientist in our organization
he's working on a lot of interesting
things like fraud detection driver
allocation personalization and
forecasting so he's got projects all
across the board and we thought that if
we solved areas problems then we could
solve all the data scientists related
related inefficiencies so we looked at
where Darius was spending his time and
this is what we found so this is a bar
of the where Darius is spending his time
on a typical project so as part of his
life cycle of his project and we we
honed in on the different tasks that he
was doing the gray areas represent task
which we didn't deem to be not really
data side not really data science per se
so
these are tossed like provisioning
infrastructure installing software it's
kind of a systems and engineering
related work that Darius was doing and
then if you look at the colored blocks
there is all of the data science related
tasks that he's an expert at that he's
good at doing so we wanted him to focus
more on that and less on the engineering
and if you have a call center on one day
and then a few years later you have a
unicorn billion-dollar company with
thousands of employees and you tell data
scientists to deliver results then you
get something like this because data
scientists will need to provision infra
if there's no platform for them to build
on but they've all these ancient systems
so what we told there is was that we're
gonna we're gonna try and solve your
inefficiencies and problems and we're
gonna look at all of your projects
through three different lenses the first
is the sourcing of data the second is
feature engineering and the final one
will be machine learning and by looking
at these three aspects we'll we're going
to try and improve your the way you're
spending your time so that you can focus
more on your own data science and
machine learning so the first of the
three is sourcing of data and this is a
very foundational block that we had to
address before we could get on to
machine learning and feature engineering
so we're all serious can you give us an
example of a project that you were
working on where you had troubles with
sourcing of data and and this is what he
told us he says he was working on an
exploratory data analysis project he had
this hypothesis that if you are if a
driver is going to pick up a customer
the closer they are to the customer the
quicker it will be to pick up that
customer except the bit of info data t
had didn't indicate that the opposite
was actually true so the closer of the
core is to the customer for some drivers
the longer it takes them to pick up the
driver and this was very
counterintuitive so he what he said was
okay he's going to investigate why this
is the case so what he did is he asked
so what he wanted to do is he wanted to
look at the specific drivers in more
detail so he wanted more details but
data on the drivers so he asked other
data scientists in his team for and for
this data and they didn't have it he
hosts his manager he asked the VP of
data science he was the CTO
if
he was directed to a team in Bangalore
that could potentially have this data
and it turns out they did have the data
so what they told him was that he can't
query their production database because
it'll lock the TV and it will ruin the
driver experience and so the problem
here is that this is not really Darius's
job to hunt after data so we knew that
this is something that we needed to
address before we could get to any of
the m/l or feature engineering so our
realization was don't go to the data the
data come to you so the key thing here
is that there is and we have to go after
the data and we need we realized we
needed to centralize data storage within
our organization and we did it through
the following means we said we're gonna
build a data foundation and we're gonna
bring in all the data from all the
product teams that are being created on
a very frequent basis and we're gonna do
this with three components bigquery
Kafka and cloud storage so bigquery will
become our data warehouse this is a kind
of no-brainer I don't know if I have to
sell anybody in bigquery it's big data
storage scales it's easy to access
sequel Kafka we needed some of the
functionality in Kafka that's what we
opted for Kafka in this case but we do
use pub/sub as well but the café's
industry-standard event bus and cloud
storage as our data leg the problem with
this is though that even if you
standardize publishing of data to a
centralized location you you have to
force people either through a stick or a
carrot to do that right and we wanted to
actually give them some benefits or
incentives to publish so what we said is
if you publish your data to the to the
foundation we'll give you some benefits
and the benefits that we gave them were
reporting one so the time managers were
happy so we automatically generate
reports based on the data that you
publish there we give you a dramatic
archival we give you automatic
monitoring of an alerting of your events
on Capcom and then finally because
you're using bigquery and other
and other Google services like cloud
storage you have centralized with
indication and authorization built-in so
with all these benefits that we gave all
the product teams and other teams in the
organization they started publishing
data and once they started publishing
data people like Darius and analysts and
other employees could then find data and
and inverse led to more insights and so
what Darius that is he went back and he
looked at those drivers with the weird
pattern of taking very long to reach
customers and this is what he found so
here two images that illustrate what
there is found when he looked at these
drivers on the left there is a driver
that's permanently stationed on a
building and he's just always sitting
there and on the right there's a driver
that is moving through a bunch of
buildings that 106 kilometers an hour
now then in miles per hour I don't know
what that is that's like 60 or 70 miles
per hour but the point is that it's
impossible in Jakarta nobody moves at a
speed that's like the speed of light in
Jakarta so what we realized is that
these drivers were actually faking their
location that were using software that
allowed them to pretend to be at a
specific location so that they could get
preferential treatment by our machine
learning models when they were being
assigned to trips so in that case the
driver was pretending to be in the
shopping mall and then if somebody
leaves the shopping mall that he would
be assigned to that trip but in reality
he's actually far away and then he would
have to drive there right so armed with
this knowledge Darius could then have
could then go and pull the model that
could identify these drivers and then
react accordingly so the key thing here
is building a data foundation is fun
foundational and fundamental part of
solving ML problems and you shouldn't be
hiring data scientists or not at least
not many until you've bought this
fundamental block so so this was the
first part that we did right and feature
engineering is the second part so we are
serious about how we could what projects
he has in feature engineering where he
had frustrations with working with free
features so he told us about another
project and this one is a lot more
important for the Gajic so this is the
driver allocation problem so there is
told us how this works
so basically if you have if you're a
customer and you're making a request for
a booking to go to a destination you
need to be assigned a driver most
customers think that okay they just want
the closest driver that's right next to
them you know oftentimes you can see on
your little app there's a driver right
outside your door and you wonder why
doesn't this algorithm allocate this
driver but it's often a very complex
process right because sometimes drivers
want to head home sometimes drivers are
on a trip sometimes they've just made a
turn onto an highway and they're gonna
take a long time to turn around
sometimes you want to optimize for the
driver experience because they're also
part of our system right so the drivers
might not have had an opportunity for a
long time to take a trip with a customer
so they're also trying to earn a living
so basically dairies realize that the
driver allocation problem is one that is
very dependent on features because the
features will really drive the decision
making of the model and this model is
actually extremely important for our
organization if you're doing a hundred
million bookings every month this models
gonna process a lot of money and a small
tweak to this model can have a massive
impact on the bottom line right and so
diría said okay let's first make a list
of all the features we need so he starts
listening down the features and these
are some of the typical features that
there is off the top of his head came up
with so their driver letter features
like what is this location speed
direction ETA so focused on the driver
features and then there's also customer
related features like the profile what
their clicks or their actions and their
history then their own spatial features
like what's the demand in this area
that's the supply like traffic related
features and then finally temporal
features like what's the time of the day
what's the day of the week is it a
public holiday often in Indonesia you
have religious holidays that can
completely change the way that traffic
behaves and how supply and demand
dynamics change so he made this list of
features and then he said about creating
these features so that he could train a
model and then you know deploy his model
into production but he ran into some
problems and these were some of the
problems that he ran into
so the first problem we ran into was the
volume of feature data so we had the
data foundation now and what Darius was
doing is he was splitting up virtual
machines and he was scheduling jobs that
would transform that information into
features and then publish it somewhere
and then he would train a model on those
features this is a batch process is an
offline process but it's a scheduled one
the trick here is that for data
scientists that's a lot of work these
pipelines run for hours and days the
iteration cycle is very slow and making
a small tweak it means you have to rerun
the whole pipeline making a mistake
means you have to start all over so this
is a frustration that is costing us a
lot of time data science hours something
we wanted to solve the second problem we
had was with real time features so you
can imagine if you have a calf car in
the rain stream you can't just run a
query on Kafka right you need to
actually build a system that streams
that data into a data store and with
transformations that pulls features and
then you can access those features in
real time so every time we wanted to
launch a project we needed an engineer
to come in and build a system that could
stream these or and events and both
features for real-time access so this is
something we wanted to solve across the
board the third problem we had was
consistency we had engineers now
building features in real time and then
we had Darius building a Tim batch but
these were disconnected the real-time
features were in Java and go and other
languages like Scala and Darius was
building these features in Python so
there's an inconsistency there and this
creates a problem because models are
being trained on one set of features and
they're being served in production with
different features and this real scope
for problems to come in also there's a
duplication of work you actually just
wanted to find a feature once not twice
and then finally discovery so Darius
actually went to lunch with the data
scientist and he realized that this data
scientist had already developed a lot of
the features that Darius had developed
and so there is was redeveloping the
same features due to a lack of knowledge
and a lack of discovery in the
organization so we really wanted to we
knew we needed to solve this problem
holistically for the whole organization
so that the discovery was there and the
standardization was there
so our realization was that feature
should be free you're gonna have to pay
a cost to both features the first time
and but after that it should be
available in all of your environments
consistently production for serving and
for training and it should be
discoverable and you should have
information about your features so we
were gonna put in bold is a platform for
Darius to access features and create
features and the first part of that
platform is data flow so we had our data
sources now with our data foundation and
we needed a way to solve the consistency
problem and how we did that is by
introducing data flow so what's great
about data flow and wide so suited for
this purpose is because we want
consistency right we don't want to
redefine the same features over and over
and with data flow batch and stream are
supported as first-class citizens
there's really no distinction between
the two there are just different data
sources so with data flow you can take
in CSV you can take in events you can
take in sequel sequel relational data
and then transform it with a single
transformation and produce it into any
kind of data store so by introducing
data flow we have a single place where
Darius can bold his or define his
feature some of the other advantages of
dataflow is that is automatically scales
there's no servers to manage there's no
lock in because the code that you write
on data flow the API is called beam
Apache beam you can be run on flink it
can be run on spark so there is a
portability to the code you write so
you're not locked into data flow so some
of the challenges with data flow is that
because it's streaming and batch in all
cases the API is kind of tricky
you're also limited by the fact that -
and go lang support is not as feature
full as Java so in most cases you'll be
forced to write Java code so that's the
trick with beam and data flow I'm
certain often in the case where this is
you'll need an engineer to help define
the features with the data scientist but
the key cookie thing here is once it's
defined it's done
it's always there and it you can store
your features then in training the
training store as well as a real time
store
so here's an example of a feature
definition so in this case we're just
going to look at how many trips the
driver has completed in the day and we
take trip events this code is Python
code and then you apply the P transforms
on the P collection so the trip events
is a collection of events or elements
and then you apply subsequent
transformations like you filter out all
the successful trips so generally left
with that you add you create a data
structure with a count of one per event
and then you just do a group by and then
you're left with the count for all of
the drivers so this is a very basic
example of how you could define a
feature although in our case oftentimes
we use Java to define this but it has a
lot more boilerplate right so now you've
solved the feature creation and
standardization and consistency problem
but now we need to introduce storage as
well so for training we introduced
bigquery so bigquery is just a
no-brainer store for us we looked at a
lot of competing databases to store
training data but ultimately it came
down to one thing our label data is
generally in the data sources and raw
data and our feature data often needs to
be joined onto our label data to create
training sets so we didn't want to have
a completely distinct training store or
at least not for as there at least not
if we didn't have a good reason so we
opted for bigquery because of its high
scalability and the fact that it's a
completely cloud-based service even have
to manage any infrastructure easy to
access sequel based for this use case is
also very good because generally
features are represented as columns in
this data store and bigquery is a column
restore so it's very efficient at
querying feature data all right so
that's what we introduced for our
training store it's also very closely
integrated with other cloud services on
Google cloud but we'll get to that later
so if we're serving we introduced two
data stores the first is BigTable and
the second is cloud memory store or
Google's hosted Redis BigTable was
really a game changer for us not just
for features but for other applications
as well and the reason why it's so good
is because
it allows you to consistently access
feature data at very low latency so less
than 10 milliseconds guaranteed it
allows you to handle very high load so
you can write and read to it up to
10,000 times per second
combined per node right and if you want
to scale up you just add more nodes
right so you can scale up linearly to
any amount of nodes with big table and
then we also introduced cloud memory
store Redis for a similar use case so
sometimes when you have hundreds of
thousands of drivers there's so many
features and some of those features
change so frequently that the load is
just incredible right so you're gonna
have to spin up maybe 50 BigTable nodes
to handle that load so let's say you
you're you're you need to update some
features at a rate of 200 or 300
thousand times per second
it doesn't make sense to use BigTable
Matthew scales so that you get a few
scares so we introduced radius because
radius allows you to read and write at
extremely high rate often for these
types of features we don't care if the
datastore dough goes down so the
durability of radius is not really a
concern for us and then ultimately we
slept on top of this whole system a
feature serving API this API just
intelligently finds where the features
are located so if our future lookup
request comes in it breaks support that
request and finds the data and joins it
back and also very importantly there's
also caching in the features serving API
without that caching it's extremely
difficult to handle the load but now if
you look at this chart you actually have
a lot of information about the features
you've got data flow when you're
creating your features you know what
features you've defined you've got the
axis on a feature serving API like how
which features are being used the most
and then you've got the training store
where your training data store bigquery
where you're creating training data sets
and training models and you know how
good those models are performing at
inference right so with all this data if
you log it it's very useful to data
scientists actually and so what we did
is we just dump all of that metadata
about features into a database and then
we just slept on top of that data studio
so this is just a bi tool essentially
that allows you to look at data and we
can see the relative efficacy or
impact that specific features have
relative to each other for predicting
outcomes or optimizing for specific
objectives and if you expose this to
data scientist then it's a really
powerful tool for some key insights and
also even if you didn't have any of the
impact if you just had a list of
features that's already useful to data
scientists because then they can take
this list and say ok I'm gonna get a big
query and just select these specific
features and train my model and then
finally this is what we've built so
we've got our data sources we've got a
standard way in which Darrius can define
a feature to transform those data
sources he doesn't have to worry about
the training store he doesn't have to
worry about memory store a big table he
doesn't have to worry about the serving
API all he needs to do is find features
in the Explorer select them in bigquery
and Chinese model and then remember
which features are available in the
future serving API so so we've solved
his driver allocation problem to large
degree because the feature engineering
was the toughest part for him all he
needs to do now is define features as
feature transforms the final part that
we're gonna look at is machine learning
right so we've got both of the
foundational blocks now of the data
sources and feature engineering so that
let's have a look at some of the
projects that Darius was looking at or
was working on for machine learning so
dynamic pricing is one of the key things
that all Ryan Hayling companies must
make or must bold so the problem here is
that if you don't have done any pricing
then you have any efficiencies in your
market so you have customers and drivers
and they need to be matched the drivers
need to service your customers but if if
there's not enough
drivers in an area you me to incentivize
drivers to move into that area and
services customers and you do this by
having variable pricing and specific
reason regions so here's just an example
of a neat map in Jakarta where the
center of Jakarta has a higher higher
prices than in make parts Kurt's right
and this is just to minimize drivers to
move into that area to service those
customers so when we started with this
model or this project
Darius said ok he's just gonna take data
that's one big query tryna
male model and he's gonna deploy it and
that's what he did he trained a model on
some of the data he had some ideas and
he deployed it on the outskirts of one
of the towns as a small experiment but
there were some problems the first
problem he had was a didn't scale so his
model was written in Python it couldn't
scale out of that experimental base the
second model a second problem was with
this model that it was not interpretable
it was a black box and nobody else in
the organization could explain what it
was doing and the third problem was even
if we could look at the results of the
model we didn't know if it was good or
bad because this is actually extremely
challenging problems you solve it's very
difficult to have a baseline or a
control in this dynamic pricing problem
if you have an experiment where you're
raising prices in one area you're
affecting essentially the whole world
it's there's no isolation or I poster
apples comparison so you're raising
prices you're pulling in supply from
external areas and we had other issues
as well so let's say you've got food as
one of your products a food delivery and
then you've also got essentially people
delivery on go ride they share a supply
base so if you raise the price on the go
right side then you're taking riders or
people that deliver food away from your
other product and this is what we found
that we needed to have a very clear
balance between our products in terms of
dynamic pricing so this was our
realization do machine learning like the
great engineer you're not like the great
machine learning expert you aren't and
this was important for us so the reason
for this is that we knew we were making
a mistake by jumping into ml so what we
did first is we define our objective we
both take very clear a very solid
engineering system that could handle the
load and that could handle a very basic
mathematical model not a machine
learning model and we deployed this with
clear objectives with a clear
measurement of success with clear
dashboards and monitoring and everything
without any machine learning
and then we had dynamic pricing and now
drivers could see in specific areas
where the prices were higher or lower
and then they could in service those
areas that were incentivized to go there
ultimately we would end up adding
machine learning to the system but at
the start the key thing was knowing what
yours what your success criteria is and
building a rock-solid engineering system
first right
but there's still some inefficiencies in
the system so what what all of the
drivers were complaining to Darius about
was that okay you can see that there are
some areas that are high in the mod but
it's high in the morn for a reason it's
not high in the mall from the reason the
the fact of the matter is that there's
high traffic or there's a bottleneck or
there's some reason why it's it's not
hard to get there so if they had some
way to know in advance that there's
gonna be high demand that would help
them and this is good for costing came
in there is knew that he could actually
forecast wanted amount would be like in
those areas and so he said about or this
is what he told us building a model that
would do forecasting so he would take
all of the data all of the supply data
demand data traffic data user click
stream data all the signals that he
could get on a per region basis so this
is an extremely large amount of data
terabytes and terabytes of data that he
was streaming and it was so large that
or this model was so complex that we
even took bulk weather stations in
Jakarta and streamed in weather data
because if rain falls in Jakarta then
traffic will immediately change very
quickly so what he wanted to do is he
wanted to take all this data through a
TF model and then predict on a per
region basis wrapper area basis what did
Amon would be but he ran into some
challenges as usual so one of the things
that one of the problems he ran into was
that you couldn't actually train this
model on his local machine even as it
just a taste on a subset of the data and
when he tried to move the data on to a
virtual machine and train it there it
also fell over the virtual machine just
couldn't load all of his data into
memory so what he did is he asked a
bunch of engineers
ok can you help me spin up a spark
cluster and train the model there and so
they did that and
worked they use spark and they they
train the model and they could actually
deploy it but now there's a problem
because there is is dependent on these
engineers every time he wants to make a
change in his lost engineers can you
help me with this cluster and another
problem we had was that it was actually
quite slow it would take hours and
sometimes more than a day to train this
model so the lesson here was don't break
abstraction if your data scientists try
and operate with the appropriate tooling
at the abstraction layer that you're
comfortable with and that you're an
expert at don't drop down into the
engineering world unless you absolutely
have to and as a data science platform
lead it's my responsibility to give day
Darius the tools that he needs to
operate at this abstraction layer so
what we introduced today is was cloud ml
engine so the system one of the reasons
we also chose bigquery as our feature
and we're all data warehouse so it's
it's got a very close integration with
cloud ml engine so the client email
engine it allows you to train tensor
flow models it's a completely managed
service it's scales and matically
training is distributed and there's some
other advantages like you've got hyper
parameter tuning which means your models
can be more accurate you've got levers
that you can pull if you want to iterate
and train faster you can go from CPUs
GPUs GPUs so this is what we introduced
to Darius and the way he used it was as
follows he's got his future
transformations already so he's got his
data flow creating features into
bigquery those are the time series
signals that he is getting from the
field like the weather data that I spoke
of he trains the model on cloud ml
engine and he serves it on cloud ml
engine then he's signals are coming from
Kefka as well so these are the raw
events and then he's got a separate
stream that does inference so this is
just a cloud that ever job that triggers
serving on cloud ml engine so if rain
falls it'll trigger cloud ml engine for
new inference predict the demand and
then publish it back to Kafka
and so this worked one of the downsides
to using cloud email engine is that it
only supports training for tensorflow so
he only is HT boost or scikit-learn or
any of these it doesn't work for
training you can serve those the other
types of models but there are some
downsides but for us the key thing was
we wanted to have at least one tool that
the data scientist could use without
having to pull in engineers so then we
had forecasting so these are just three
of the different regions so here's a
30-minute forecast the green line
represents one of the forecast and the
yellow line represents one of the were
the actual values and so we knew what
the demand would be in the future we
could tell drivers this is an area
that'll be in high in the one or we
could just change the pricing and that
will also influence the way the drivers
react to the dynamics but this wasn't
Darius toughest challenge Darius had
other challenges as well the toughest
challenge Darius had was on the
homescreen of our application so this is
our home screen and you can see at the
top there some products I go ride and go
car in those but at the bottom if you
can actually scroll down there's a very
long feed and we have full control over
what we display on that feed and for us
it's extremely important to personalize
our application all of our customers use
our application for different reasons
some order foods some buy groceries some
use it as a ride hailing application if
you have a teen press products you need
to customize it and as a business you
have objectives like you want to
introduce new products to certain
customers so this is a very important
part of our application so Darius was
tasked with building this model to what
his model would get is the user
information so the users ID
it's the user's location and the time at
which the user has opened the
application and then what he has to
respond with is a list of
recommendations to personalize this home
screen but this is actually quite
challenging because that data is only
available to us when the user opens the
application see the trick here is that
we don't track users when they're not
inside of our application so we don't
know where or when you're gonna open the
application until you do it and the type
of personalization we want
or Darius described it as follows he
said that they say you know that a
person will order a pizza for his
children on a Friday night he's been
doing it for three weeks in a row so you
want to be able to recommend that buying
a pizza to him if you doubt if it
arrives at home on that Friday night
again but if it arrives at the office or
if your eyes at the friend's house then
you don't want to recommend that right
so that's the type of control we want in
personalization so so there were some
[ __ ] the challenge is of course that we
don't know where where when the user
will pop up so there is said okay fine
he's gonna try and build a model and to
see if he can serve this right so here
are his targets on the right so he needs
to serve the response in 30 milliseconds
it's the home screen of the application
so you have to serve responses very
quickly our SL is at 10,000 requests per
second so the heart the throughput is
very high and with international
expansion we knew we needed to support
even higher throughput soon so this was
this model that he both was an
application it was embedded within an
application and it was before we had the
feature platform so in this case he
actually had user data that was loaded
into the application statically as batch
data so he would get the user ID the
time and the lat/long
when the user opens the application and
then what he would do is he would
transform based on the user data as well
as the incoming request new features he
wouldn't Agenor eight new features put
it into the change of flow model do
inference and then it'll produce a list
of recommendations which he would return
and so what there is there is he did a
benchmark he's just had a look at what
performance he's actually getting with
this application
and this was his initial performance his
target is 30 milliseconds but he was
serving results at 140 milliseconds
which is almost five times to slow so as
any engineer will tell you the first
thing you do in kubernetes is you scale
it out and that's what we did of course
that doesn't really solve your problem
right there's a certain amount of
complexity and producing these results
or and doing inference and scanning out
will just reduce the load it won't
actually minimize the latency that much
so then eventually what we did is we
introduced the featured platform and by
doing that we could externalize a lot of
the features outside of this application
so that only the model is hosted in the
application and so that's what we did
but the latency was still too slow I was
taking too long to serve results and we
couldn't actually deploy this at scale
in production it would be too disruptive
to the user experience and we really hit
a wall here and this is a common problem
because each project has a unique model
with its own characteristics a
completely unique system and so we
mulled over this and we came to
realization we should pre compute
everything of course in this case it's
not that easy to just pre compute
everything because you don't know where
users will be and you don't know when
they'll open the application and you
don't know which user it'll be so the
amount of combinations is immense
if you have many tens of millions of
users you need to somehow reduce the
amount of predictions or recommendations
that you want to pre-compute
and the way we did that is by doing two
things the first is we bucket locations
in two areas so we say all the areas all
the locations within a football field
sized area counts as that area and then
we bucket time into Windows of let's say
30 minutes or an hour then for each
customer so for each of our millions of
customers and for each of these tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
areas and for each of these time buckets
we produce a customized personalized
recommendation but you're still talking
about hundreds or more billions of
recommendations for a single model so
really really big datasets terabytes and
terabytes of data and of course the
solution that we presented was BigTable
to store this data so it's one of the
few tools that we have found that can
actually store and serve all of these
recommendations so the way that we
changed there is a system was as
followed for as follows
so users now have specific actions that
they take like let's say that you buy a
pizza on a Friday night that is
something that describes your behavior
we log that as an event on caprica and
then we have a dataflow job that hosts a
model attention flow model and this
model streams in this event and then it
produces personalized recommendations
for that user based on the unique
behavior of that user and then it stores
all of these recommendations or it just
updates the existing recommendations in
BigTable and so this process continually
happens behind the scenes and now our
model service has changed now our model
service is a lookup service right and so
the lookup server is always doing is
just looking at BigTable at a specific
landing zone where that information is
found and I just retrieves it and serves
it so if you think about this this
paradigm shift is very powerful as an
engineer because your machine learning
system is completely disconnected from
the serving infrastructure if you if you
delete or if you remove all of the email
pipelines and the event stream you still
have BigTable that's independently
testable that you know the
characteristics of it can handle
terabytes of data it can serve responses
at 10 milliseconds and you'll never have
an issue as long as you've tasted at
least once for your use case so this is
what we presented for Daria's and when
we looked at the performance it was good
enough 15 milliseconds you're always
going to hit that 50 milliseconds
there's enough buffer of course this
doesn't solve all of your problems as an
engineer or data scientist some models
you can't recompute some you always have
to have a model in the service but if
you have the option think about storing
very large amounts of data as an option
or an alternative to serving models in
production because of the production
ionization or abilities of that so what
are the impacts of these changes that we
introduced to Darius originally when we
looked at Darius's workflow in a typical
project he was spending a lot of time I
was provisioning infrastructure
instantly software all of these tasks
that were not really
data science related right we wanted him
to focus more on what he's good at which
is creating features of living models
evaluating experiments and things so we
introduced what is essentially a
platform but both on Google Cloud and if
you look at the data sources we've got
all the types of data source that you
want that Lake you've got a vein stream
you've got bigquery as your data
warehouse there's a single place where
Darius can define his features in cloud
dataflow
he doesn't have to define features
anywhere else he can do inference in the
stream on data flow by hosting cloud ml
models in data flow
alternatively can also hosted on cloud
ml engine he's got his serving store in
BigTable and then cloud memory store and
a training store in bigquery and he
doesn't have to manage those most of
this infrastructure is managed by us and
it's not really managed by us as
engineers because it's all just cloud
services in most of the cases
so all Darius actually has to worry
about is doing modeling in their lab
finding features in the future Explorer
and then using bigquery to create these
training sets and using ml engine to
train those models of course they will
always be custom projects I think the
key thing here is that we introduce
technologies that allows if there is two
operators is abstraction layer where he
doesn't need to pull in engineers he can
do things on his own and it can produce
results on his own he doesn't have to
spit up infrastructure
so now Darius is using a lot less time
on a typical project he's spending more
time on developing models and because at
the time has been compressed it's faster
for him to get to market and he can take
on more projects so the impact on Gajic
is our data scientists can now deliver
projects faster we we have more touch
points we know within our application
because we can deliver more models
our customer experience has improved a
lot because now the models are more
accurate because we have more features
as well we have less data scientists per
customer and this is a great thing
because expanding to new markets you
don't necessarily want to just add new
data Sciences it was better to leverage
the existing ones you have and obviously
having less infrastructure is a big one
for us it's least less time to spend
managing infrastructure and it cost less
and just to recap the lessons later data
to come to you centralize your data
whereas don't do anything else unless
you've done that first especially if you
have a very big geographically separated
organization like we do the features
you'll pay a cost once but then after
that it should be free and available in
all of your environments and
discoverable and trackable this is also
a very important step and then the third
one was don't break abstraction if your
data scientist operates with the tools
at this abstraction layer that you are
comfortable with that your domain
expertise and then finally if you have
the option pre compute everything pre
compute results okay that's it for me
you
[Music]